Çıplak ihtiyaçları ara,
Endişelerini ve çekişmelerini unut, yani, çıplak
ihtiyaçları veya
hayatın çıplak ihtiyaçlarını getiren tabiat ananın tarifleri, Çıplak ihtiyaçları ara, basit, çıplak ihtiyaçları,
şehirleri unut Ah
tabiat ananın getiren tarifleri
hayatın çıplak ihtiyaçları
istediğim yerde, yatırım getirim ne zaman istersem
b-ama büyük bir evim var
, ikramlar bazılarını
kayaların ve bitkilerin altına bakmanızı
ve Pennsy'ye bir göz atmanızı ve belki de
birkaçını evlerde denemenizi sağlar kralın tacizcisi
köpekbalığı yapar  uzanmak iğrenç değil -
çocuk Clarice mcseamus performansında aktif bir Jedi
Mazda Chuck diyor ki Lee
ve Bosch Gotama mücevherler
Cenevre mantığında her birinin başında videolar Ah
Angela köpekbalığını kesiyor, böylece
seni boğulmuş ah genç Sibelius dürüst
onlar bir Shakopee dinami, Akuma
Vericut lakuna Derek, Alisa da
anne bir koreografi larvaları erişim
yağı kuzenimiz Eric Oh Hawaii,
C yakınlarındaki sahile göz at  olumbia mrs.  Lily o
en emin bounnam yapılmalı Borneo
Ritz köpekbalığının üzerine koyduğu halı parçası
başka bir mistik pencere algılıyor
kuzushi Madoka'nın booboo de
américa de toksik lideri en iyi alarmlar
alarm kalkış hayalet kamerada İrlanda Ligi
Aslan Denis Coderre
yükseliyor eski  Cloonan mr.  Norton merhaba
Lance condena Gondar miyopi
gözlerim
, havadaki o ünlü burundaki hali vakti yerinde Lennox Bulvarı'nı
gördünüz mü?  git neden
Harlem'in oturduğu yere gitmiyorsun
Ritz'in püsküllü kızlarını bir sürü yutturmaca üzerine aspen
aspen aşağı tüm
uyumsuzlar orası her Bell'in
her Perşembe şişmiş yaylarıyla
ovuşturarak dirsekleriyle gittiği yer benimle gel ve biz
Jübile'ye katıl ve
son iki parçalarını Ritz'e koyarak harcadıklarını gör
, bu ton üzerinde İstanbul'u söyleyemezsin
melodinin senkopu ile uyumları ile değişir
beni geri al Köstence hayır
, Konstantinopolis'e geri
dönemezsin şimdi toplandı  Bundan kaçınmak için durmayın
Konstantinopolis işleri
alın bu kimseyi ilgilendirmez ama Türkler
benimle gelsin ve Jübile'ye katılacağız
ve onların son
iki parçalarını
Ritz'e koyarak harcadıklarını göreceğiz sadece her fırsatta ciddi oyuncak bebekler olun ve koşun  y
müze tebeşir zulasında İtalyanca canlı yayında
olan Kudüs'te osurukta Franklin
Norman İngilizcesi yakınlaştığında
çene makinesini bireysel formül
Arapça
bu özlüyor eres de la latina gospel'i
kanepenin altlarında salıncak lastikleri ile
boynunda hemşire görüntüleri orijinal tico  -tico
no fubá veya 1b Brasilia müfredatın bölümleri
jüri üyeleri hoc erteleme yoluyla jakar asistanı
coca-cola mandolin
Brezilyalılara verilen cush troll ve chinko
ekun - emi parti mrs.  ray Andrew kardeşler
avokado Halep'teki hacimli astrolog
Yehova Cartman'ı seçti mutfak geri adam
Calliope Ramesh yakalama
Oh Chico Chico Chico Chico şans yanlış
psikopat benim sınıfımdaki guguk kuşudur ve
guguk kuşu dediğinde İsa sana
gizlice girer bataklıktaki tüm aşıklar
I  Kalpler ağır bir
randevum var Chico'mun çok akıllı olduğunu
söylüyor bana nazikçe söyledi ve son bir
yana oh küçük chica
chica'mın bana zamanı çağırdığını duyuyorum : Tiko Tiko Tiko
Tiko zaman
gıdıkla gıdıkla gıdıkla gıdıkla gıdıkla
gıdıkla
yani anahtar  parça ziller ADA Ruth
Haversham tarife 9 smoosh spiedini
parsha penceresi kou Zi botanik olarak
escapar aldık baş mimarlar sağır
sanatçılar emlakçının imzası dinamik
moonkin çember kırılmayacak mı
dedim
ve onu al
köle için haklı
düşeceğim
ama
Tamam güle güle
bir ayı
var oğlum
gökyüzü
Joseph es su casa
odak adam bataklık sanatçılar Issei Louie
Armstrong Louis - ich mich puja standart
Amerika the key New Orle  ans Canton no
al-mansur Allen Allison
New Orleans'ta Noel zamanı partizan vızıltısı oh [ __ ]
, kumarhaneye gidiyoruz New Orleans'ta sallanan zaman
güneş enerjisi analizi
geceleri parlayan parlak
pamuk tarlaları,
yeni Mississippi milletinde oyun zamanı salladığımda gümüşi beyaz görünen manolya ağaçları
salıncak oyunları sırasında orada toplanıyorsunuz demek
istediğim, iyi bir Creole ritmine ihtiyacınız var ve Galli
kırmızı demek istiyor, sadece Mason Caddesi'nde duyabiliyorsunuz,
tüm SAT'ları burada yaptığınızda umurlarınız kaybolacak
Mama, salıncak oyunları sırasında burada demek istiyorum,
Ah
bir güvenlik alıyor  Şurada
Hampi Riesling seramiklerindeki şu Samoalar
bizim bölgemize boyun eğdi evet lütfen
İngilizce tamam oturumumuzun
konusu katırlar Sadece çok kısa söylemek istiyorum
kısacası benim için ne anlama geliyor
kullandığımızın anlamı bir ilham anlamına geliyor bu bir
motivasyon değil  ve benim için ilham her
zaman motivasyondan daha önemlidir
ve bazen insanlar bunu yaparlar,
yapmazlar
ve diğer bir şey de şudur ki  Bazen
gazeteciler
bir sanatçıyla röportaj yaparken,
hangi sanatçının bundan hoşlanmadığını
soruyorlar, örneğin en sevdiğiniz
müzisyen nedir, modeliniz nedir ne
düşünüyorsunuz ve oradaki bazı müzisyenler
elbette iyi diyorlar.  benim modelim de Louie
Armstrong veya Mozart veya Beethoven'dı
ve sadece onu olduğundan daha iyi sunmak
için gerçekten biliyor musun Gerçekte
biliyorsun bu soruya cevabım şu ki
, böyle bir favorim yok
, kavga edebilirim.  En sevdiğim müzisyen
ve herkesten ilham
alabilirim Sadece
sokak
müzisyenlerinden veya çatal müzisyenlerden çalan birinden ilham alabilirim ayrıca
aslında çalıştığım grupla bir ilham bulabilirim
quiz yani
bulduğum bir şey bu  bu benim
ilham kaynağım tamam
laik takımı aldı performans
anne/kız Larocque barabar sodyum
çok sınırlı karışımlarda yumurta salatası
musakka PMDB hangi pamuğun
o olarak adlandırıldığı  Bir kasap gurusunun büyük oğlu
kendi yargıç mişinin kehaneti
Andrews Sisters bir çek boogie
salladı Woogie Bugle Boy
o Chicago'da ünlü bir trompetçiydi
bir boogie başlattı hayır ve
bu iyi iyi oynadı en iyi adam
iyi belliydi ama sonra numarası  geldi
ve o ordudaydı şimdi şirket
ayakları yani Sam Amca'ya kadar gerçekten
indirdi çünkü anlayamıyor gibiydi
çünkü bir sonraki
şapkada bir adamı evlat edineceğim ve tüm
şirket o oynadığında atlar  aileyi
yeniden canlandırdı şirketi bir ukala olmak
B Şirketi meşgul bir arı olarak meşguldü
ve siz kopyaları yapmak için oynadığınızda ben
bara sekiz yaşındayım o boogie-woogie
Bugle Boy B Şirketinin diğer ikisine yalan söylemesi daha
zor  Jose,
bizim karşı üs için siparişte tuttuğu bara
bir kazanan
ve onlar atlama süpürücü olamazlar Radley
o boogie-woogie bir eş
şirketi olmak
Devonshire'da 13 olmak
efendim aynı şekilde erken
çok özel